the normally bustling streets of
london's chinatown the early evening
after work rush more a hurried walk past
half-empty restaurants there's often a
dip in trade following Chinese New Year
we're told but not like this literally
there have been a lot of booking being
cancelled the worst China actually is
very effective because of Isis literally
is from China so le was not I can say is
scared they will worry if the greenest
place like Chinatown here which can make
lot Chinese people's they said I mean
highways to to get viruses it also
happens to be the midwinter flu season
notoriously contagious sometimes deadly
but not generally known to affect
business on the high street it's
estimated the common flu accounts for
more than 50 thousand deaths a year
worldwide coronavirus on the other hand
has so far resulted in the deaths of
just over 500 people
your friend was worried why was she
won't tell me what she said she was
worried that it would in fact the food
because the people were there your
friend thought coronavirus wouldn't it
would it might affect what we eat and
a lot of people wearing masks you know
and she said maybe I should wear a mask
but you know it's just I said it's
there's no problem because I have a
people and you hear it on the news and
other people sort of get a bit scared
about it you know it put me off a bit
I've got to be honest but I thought well
we're here now aren't ways so we're
going to enjoy ourselves quite a lot of
people seem to think coronavirus is the
new plague carried by anyone who even
looks Chinese there are reports of
racism a Chinese woman on a crowded
London tube - eating that no one would
sit in the seats beside her and not just
in London
Chinese people banned from a nail bar in
Vietnam and a cafe near the Trevi
Fountain in Rome though ho-ho-ho problem
is because of the uninformed decision of
of the FL of the virus because the New
Haven news that trying to put a lot more
virus so people thought that that
challenged people various carriers I
think as these to do an informed and
educated to write and what rather than
racism I mean initially at least for now
but it does at least for now mean
quieter times in Chinatown Jonah Hal
al-jazeera London